[Musique]
je vous présente dark vador et un
astronaute qui se retrouve notamment au
milieu de cette crise qui ne passe pas
très bien auprès des fidèles qui sont
assez surpris par cette réinterprétation
inspiré d'art contemporain écouter ça me
fait penser aux quilles de bowling avec
le petit jésus comme bull
c'est une crèche très étrange c'est
difficile de croire qu'ils ont vraiment
fait ça je ne veux pas être méchante
mais j'ai préféré celle de l'année
dernière le pape de toute façon qui
cette année a décidé de casser toutes
les traditions je voulais aussi vous
montrer cette image regarder cet
appétissant panettones c'est normalement
le gazoduc pas passer à ses employés aux
employés de l'état du vatican même à
cette année c'est finir regardez ce
qu'ils ont reçu du paracétamol et la wii
cette année ils sont priés de se soigner
contre le rhume et la grippe par ce
qu'entendent qu'ovide il ne s'agirait
pas d'aller rencontrer les hôpitaux
italiens
je vous rappelle que nous devons tous
être bon et gentil et suivre les
consignes sanitaires est chauve sur le
destin c'est court soyez donc gentils
les uns avec les autres
noël arrive bientôt christmas is coming
chaud c'est anne hidalgo qui écope d'une
amende pour non respect de la parité
alors pas dans le même sens que
d'habitude puisque il ya trop de femmes
dans son équipe à elle ce n'est pas
banal amende de 90 mille euros c'est
notre chiffre du jour que la maire de
paris juge absurde et injuste
onze femmes ont été nommées à des postes
de direction ce qui fait 69 % des
effectifs
pour une fois mais il ya quelque chose
que vous ignorez peut-être sur moi c'est
que j'ai
une assistance je vais la virée nous
fait rencontrer donc à la fête des
voisins et j'habite est donc encore chez
ma mère à l'époque et en fait quand on
est presque décidé de se mettre ensemble
il m'a dit d'un truc as tu m'avais dit
non j'aurais essayé ta mère voilà donc
qui n'a pas manqué de culot qua non de
couilles mais on se calme dodine est-ce
que joey starr pour être un crooner
je ne sais pas folle une vendeuse elle
fait des chansons d'amour toi en tout
cas il aime bien tout le temps des jours
son amour pour juste savoir lire entre
les lignes
[Rires]
le bot mai
ces tuyaux de la bourse était d'abord et
on a fait une version chez pasteur n'a
fait une version confinement on voit sur
son balcon lorsque tous pleins d'eau
dans le fion à bâtir football parfois il
ya des trucs qui vous tombe dessus vous
y attendais pas je me permets de citer
le rappeur booba le rapport qui booba à
ce qu'il dit sur instagram rappeur sur
sur est instagram mathieu kassovitz
grosse merde
la dernière fois que tu as fait un film
valable j'avais un magnétoscope y avait
des bouilles videofutur je sais même pas
même pas pourquoi on ta vie sur des
bandes atom ion
eh ben j'ai dit que la dernière fois que
j'ai il a fait un bond sont j'avais déjà
vu des cassettes et un walkman niveau
vous avez peur des bêtes buzz ou pas du
tout ça m'amuse
j'adorerais avoir déployé près j'adorais
on veut on peut
si vous voulez aller à hitler voilà deux
cantons fait bourdin le matin on a une
petite race raoult pas du tout petit peu
le soir déjà la veille au soir à la
veille au soir je peux vous dire quand
vous faites bernard madoff
vous dormez pas
le montant de l'amendé 135 euros s'il ya
récidive si elle récidive je crois que
c'est 1500 euros que c'est ça non non
elle dit devant 200 euros ce sont les 15
jours et après dans les 15 jours et
après 6,3 infecte eurent trois
infractions dans les 30 jours après je
crois qu'on arrive à 1500 noms dites-moi
3700 3750 six mois de prison pour gérer
les conflits
les bonobos ont une façon bien à eux de
communiquer donc c'est les bonobos la
réduction de la tension ça passe par les
interactions sexuels qui sont là pour
non seulement réduire le stress mais
aussi pour renforcer les liens
faites l'amour pas la guerre
j'aimerais donc vous présenter le
nouveau membre de la famille voici
lucifer
[Musique]
il appelle l'uci pour faire court c'est
une amie à moi carroll qui m'en a fait
cadeau formidable elle garde la maison
et s'assure que tout le monde porte des
vêtements à la mode avant de franchir le
pas de la porte d'auteuil quoi du coup
quand tu marques tu fais ça genre non
non je prends avec la main parce que là
il ya une licorne qui tâche est sûre si
je viens
[Musique]
un chef-d'oeuvre merci du mozart du
mozart non mais c'est pas du mozart
mozart c'est un facteur 2020 covit 19
kovy de 20 kw à 8 20 avait fermement
pékin nouveau qua non moi je suis encore
sur le faux qu'ovide le vert tout le
temps donc même sans voix vide est-ce
que c'est pas les scientifiques compris
le pouvoir politique et que le politique
ne fait que les suivre et ça ça ça alors
pour moi il ya quelque chose de gênant
alors bon si c'était le cas je
remercierai la science et et nous donne
pas ce que parce que c'est 2 c'est comme
ça que la politique devrait être menée
faits par des scientifique toute la
vérité sur la 5g la salle j provoque des
insomnies ça a été démontré la 5g a été
créé à tchernobyl alors c'est fort
probable l'a5 gérant les chauves
impuissant c'est exact l'a5 gérant les
impuissants chauffe ce normal ça marche
dans les deux sens
la 5g déclenche aussi les alarmes
incendie ça ça m'étonnerait
[Musique]
je laisse le mot de la fin au président
de la république de l'époque et comme le
dit jean paul rouve dans la vie je suis
bien fait ce qu'il peut